problem 31 use the problem below to
answer the question that follows all
right so this is our problem a red car
and a blue car compete in two 100 mile
races
that's the first race that's the second
race in the first race both cars leave
the starting line at the same time
that's right there when the red car
crosses the finish line the blue car has
10 miles left to go they drew that right
there red car crosses the fish climb
blue car has 10 miles left to go in the
second race both cars start at the same
time but while the blue car begins at
the starting line right there
the red car begins 10 miles behind the
starting line fair enough assuming that
each car's average speed does not change
that's a big assumption so i'm assuming
from race to race to have the same
average speed how far is the blue car
traveled in the second race when the red
car reaches the finish line so the red
car reaches the finish line the blue car
has traveled this distance x that's what
they want us to solve for for x how far
has the blue car traveled when the red
car finishes the
the finish line now this statement right
here assuming that each car's average
speed at least in my brain is a big clue
it tells us that's important that their
average speed is the same so from race
to race they don't have obviously the
same average speed the red car is faster
in either case
so let's say that r is equal to the
red's
speed
and let's say that blue is equal to
blue's
speed
now in either situation either drawing
let's say in the first race they both
traveled the same amount of time the
same amount of time it took the red car
to go the whole hundred miles the blue
car traveled this distance which is 90
miles how did i know 90 miles because he
has 10 miles left to go in a 100 mile
race
so if we know that distance is equal to
sometimes you say speed times time or
rate times time i'll use speed just
because i already used r is equal to
speed times time that also tells us that
time is equal to distance divided by
speed so in the first race
in race
one
the time that the red car took to finish
the 100 miles is 100 miles
100 miles
divided by
r
miles per hour
miles
per hour notice if the units will cancel
out properly if you divide miles by
miles per hour you're left just with
hours so this is the time it takes for
red for the first car to finish the race
now we also know it's the same amount of
time it took the blue car to go 90 miles
so that is going to be equal to
90 miles
over
b or blues
miles
per hour
right that's what the first race tells
us now what does the second race tell us
the second race we can do the same logic
race two
so
in the time it takes the red car to
travel 110 miles right he drives the
whole hundred miles and he started 10
miles back
so the red car 110 miles
divided by red miles
per hour
is equal to
is equal to what it's equal to
x the distance the blue car travels it's
equal to x miles
divided by
blues miles per hour b
miles
per
hour just like that now what do we have
here we want to solve for x and maybe
just maybe we can if we can find an
expression for r the ratio between r and
b then maybe we can solve for x let me
show you what i mean by that let me
switch colors to make this a little bit
less monotonous so this first from race
one we got the information that 100
over r is equal to 90
90 over b
so if we multiply both if we cross
multiply we essentially get 100
b 100 times b is equal to 90
times r
if we divide both sides by 90 we get 100
over 90
b is equal to r if you divide both sides
by b
and you swap the sides you get r over b
is equal to 100
over 90. so we know what the ratio of
red speed to blue speed is it's a
hundred to ninety now can we do the same
thing here let me do this in red
or maybe or no it's red okay so here if
we cross multiply from race two we have
1 10 over r is equal to x over b if we
cross multiply we get 110
b is equal to
r x
and then let's see if we divide both
sides by x we get 110 over x
b is equal to r
and then if we divide both sides by b we
get 110 over x
is equal to r
over b that's the information that the
second race gave us now the first race
already told us what r over b is equal
to is equal to 100
over 90. so we can replace r over b
based on the information in the first
race with 100
over
with 100 over 90. now let's see so our
big takeaway notice they don't want us
to solve for x they just want us to set
up the problem
is
over x
is equal to
over 90. now let's see which of these
choices say that
over x
110 over x is equal to 100 over 9.
that's choice a just like that
next problem
next problem all right
the diet use the diagram below to answer
the question that follows the diagram
above is used to describe the
relationship between the circumference
right the circumference is going around
the circle the radius the radius that's
the radius and the area of a circle the
area we know the area is assuming that
the circle is divided into enough
sections so that the figure on the right
approximates a rectangle which of the
following relationships is demonstrated
so here they they divide it into six
wedges you can look like a trivial
pursuit piece and they put them all up
but you can imagine if you'd made the
wedges even thinner if you made it if
you divide it into 12 wedges it would
start to look like this
it would look like this if you did into
12 wedges
it would and if you did into 24 wedges
it would start looking more and more
like a rectangle that looks like
it looks something like that the more
you divide the wedges it looks more and
more like that so let's see what they're
trying to show us so this is r right
here on the wedges
this distance or actually this distance
is also r
right that distance is also r
and if this is the whole thing is
obviously the circumference over here on
our kind of approximated rectangle
what's our circumference well our
circumference is that plus that plus
that plus that plus that plus that
so if we just look at maybe the base of
our rectangle that is one-half
one-half our circumference
right that's one-half our circumference
because our circumference is these arcs
plus this arc these three arcs so this
is just half of them so the area of the
rectangle
the area of this rectangle which is the
same thing as the area of this circle
because it all we did is we just kind of
cut up the circle and rearranged it into
a rectangle we approximated a rectangle
the area of the circle or the rectangle
is going to be the base which is equal
to one-half
times the circumference
times the height which is the radius
which is the radius and well looking for
me that's actually the actual choice
choice a
just like that actually this is a fun
exercise and this maybe i'll do a whole
video explaining
why area is one half the radius times
the circumference using this example
because if you divide it more into more
and more and more uh into more and more
wedges it's going to look more and more
like a rectangle i'll leave that for you
to experiment with
problem 33
a pretzel company sells pretzels in a
cylindrical container with a radius of
10 centimeters and a height of 30 let me
draw it
so cylindrical container radius is 10
centimeters and then the height
of our container
is 30
centimeters right it's all centimeters
the company's packaging designers are
considering switching to a new
cylindrical container with a radius of
20 so it's bigger radius radius of 20
centimeters and a height of 15
centimeters
a height of 15 centimeters how does the
volume of the proposed new container
compare to the volume of the old
container so the old container's volume
is going to be this area times the
height so it's going to be so the volume
is equal to the area pi r squared
r is 10
r squared is 100 so it's going to be 100
pi that's the area up here that's 100
pi and then we're going to multiply that
times the height
times 30 centimeters and so it's going
to be equal to 3 000 pi
cubic
cubic centimeters that's our old
container our new container what's the
area up here pi r squared the area is
equal to pi times r squared r is 20. 20
squared is 400
it's 400 so our volume
our volume is equal to
is equal to 400
pi times 15 and what's 400 times 15
400 times 15 is what six thousand four
hundred times ten is four thousand four
hundred times five is two thousand right
it's six thousand so the volume of our
new container is 6 000
pi
centimeters or cubic centimeters so our
new container has twice the volume of
our old container so let's see if they
say that
let's see the volume of let's see the
volume of the new container
is twice the volume of the old container
that is correct
choice d
next problem
all right
a fuel tank
was approximately 1 8 full
after adding 50
worth of fuel the tank was three fourths
full
if the fuel cost p dollars per gallon
all right approximately how many gallons
does the tank
will hold when full
so let's see we added 50 dollars and
it's p dollars per gallon so we added
so 50
divided by p gallons
gave us took us from 1 8 to 3 4 full of
a tank so how much did it add it it went
we went from three fourths of a tank
from 1 8 of a tank to 3 4 so how much
did we add if we just take the
difference between the two we can
rewrite three fourths as 6 8 minus 1 8
equal to 5 8. so we added 5 8 of a tank
going from 1 8 to 3 4 is adding 5 8 of
the tank so this is equal to
5 8
5 8 of a tank
of a tank of gas of our fuel tank now
they're saying approximately how many
gallons does the tank hold when full and
it's all in terms of p so to solve for
one tank we can multiply both sides of
this equation times the reciprocal of
this times eight fifths
let's do that
so you multiply eight over five on the
left hand side times eight over five on
the right hand side and then you're left
with
you're well i can just cancel 5's cancel
here 8 cancel here that's why i did it
so one tank
is equal to
8 over 5 times 50 over p gallons so if
we just divide
the numerator and denominator by five
that becomes ten that becomes one eight
times ten is eighty
over p
gallons is equal to one
tank and that is choice
a
choice a
next question
a homeowner let me switch colors a
homeowner is planning to use carpet
tiles to cover the floor of a room
measuring nine feet by ten feet eight
inches so it's nine feet
by
ten feet
eight inches
whenever i see that i don't know i like
to write it as a decimal or i like to
write it just purely as inches how many
inches is this one 10 feet is 120 inches
right 12 inches per foot so 120 plus 8.
so this is also this is also 128
inches i'll just write that there so
it's nine feet
by 128 inches
if the carpet tiles are eight inches
wide and one foot long and there are no
gaps between the tiles or they're placed
on the floor how many carpet tiles will
the homeowner need to cover the floor of
the room so i'm going to place them this
way just because i kept this side in
foot so i'm going to use the foot
dimension on the foot side so this is
one foot by eight inches
right that's the dimension of our tile
let me do it in a different color
it's one foot on this side right here
and then eight inches on that so clearly
we're going to be able to add we're
gonna have nine tiles because we have
nine feet
so we're gonna have nine tiles in this
direction and then how many tiles in
this direction
it's 8 inches and we have a total of 128
inches so what is how many times does 8
go into 128 8 goes into 12 once 1 times
8 is 8
48 8 goes into 48 six times so you'll
have 16 tiles in that direction nine
tiles here and the i guess in on the
width 16
tiles in the length so we're going to
have 16 times 9 tiles 6 times 9
is 54.
1 times 9 is 9 plus 5 is 14. so we're
going to need 144 tiles so that's choice
c